yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Hoffman and alejandro I think as
the name Gran maestro okay he's in Spain
but originally from Argentina okay let's
see probably Queens gambit of some sort
of reti opening yeah the Queens gambit
turn and Julia someone wanted me to play
the semi slot but let's let's stick with
let's stick with this ok now the capsule
on f6 is not it's not a bad line some
rather reliable at least ok a black has
some more than one way to deal with it
one is to earn two to play actively in
the center and not play not playing with
them c6 ok yeah oh this looks very solid
for black he doesn't really have a good
position to play against them but the
isolated the isolated pawn so he took
them going to hanging pawns formation
yeah his help is to get some play
against them c6
mmm we are night a force from the its
next move yup kids looks useful in in
most cases anyway so an idea form
yeah i can i can just take cover it with
but should be serving this pawn it's a
slightly passive
you
hmm you have how to get some come to
play I'll try to activate the rook
ok
hmm
yeah not not quite sure I mean why this
certainly some look better not sure how
much but then ok no tricky move
okay I need to take this it's not not
much choice
yeah more my bishop on the d7 wasn't
such a great piece anyway the question
is some is this really enough for for a
substantial advantage sure or not this I
can just answer with he'll be 500 always
got this square yeah this was ridiculous
completely idiotic that I overlooked the
smooth I mean I can I can just take it
and probably it's not much happening
he's got those weaknesses here as well
and now I just blundered this
yeah so this is bad yeah probably film
night this night f8 winning night f8
king and queen g6 or something and
probably yeah why should win some home
yeah I don't even have a move for me
even if it would be my move I'm not
quite sure what I would be doing
completely tied up here
Queen th may be trying to consolidate
yeah police that's easy now I don't have
one move going to DHL now are still
okay i just lost a pawn in this this
process which is not exactly great but
at least i'm not not the piece down look
down whatever can still I can still
fight on a bit yeah well do the game
continues I take a 2 here and not so
sure that is playing the sir so great
just to let us play again stay tuned
that's so stupid giving him giving me in
this yeah okay come on resins yeah this
was crap to just just overlooking this
this silly medium and and I don't think
I have any big big problems if I just
take it I mean where's I mean if you
you're not seriously thinking that this
could could lead to too wide advantage
here this is Bishop 27 ounces I can just
take it what are you doing now Knight
takes and here and this is I don't know
probably about equal I don't think that
white has any serious thing going here
so yeah I'm a slightly better for white
I don't I don't think that's something
serious going on here I can always play
d4 and exchange those two to have a
better better minor piece and i know i'm
not sure the ideas might have a wide it
is still better forward but done of
course I showed the lower queen of eight
this is a great impact our game thanks
for watching